hey thousands of years in refining super
efficient most efficient way of doing
this i would say
just like a bicycle is the most
efficient way to put put down miles
everything everything above and beyond
this is you get is a diminishing return
in energy expenditure and
productivity output
it's like meditation in motion for me
it's just really soothing and it puts
you in connection with the energy of the
earth
it's nice and quiet i could do it when
my kids were napping i could do it
in the evening i could do it early in
the morning and i didn't feel like i was
being a nuisance
i go through with one pass and then i go
back through
two or three times and you just keep
working it closer to the edge so you end
up with something that at times
depending on the grass you're cutting
you are you tailor the blade to what
you're cutting
so if i was going to be cutting really
thin delicate clover you could make this
thing you can run your fingernail
underneath it and it will create a
ripple like a wave because you make it
so thin but for the the golden rod and
red canary and that tougher kind of
stuff like that
um
that would be probably too delicate
you'd end up been fracturing it
it feels so non-destructive and gentle
and
um
life-sustaining in a sense you know when
we had the lawn mower you just run
things over and with the ham mowing you
feel like you're a part of it and you
can see the crickets and the
grasshoppers jumping out of the grass
the
mantis you know all of it it's like
you're in their environment and you're
not destroying them
and when you're mowing you really are
just focused on the sound the grass
everything else disappears
you